bonsoir merci beaucoup
alors je vais pas refaire ma
présentation mais juste vous dire que je
suis agent immobilier et comme on dit
dans le métier dans notre activité je
fais les trois métiers je suis agent
immobilier administrateurs de biens
c'est celui qui gère les appartements
pour les bailleurs et qui s'occupe des
locataires et syndics de copropriété
avant de commencer j'aurais juste besoin
de vous pour savoir un petit peu qui est
dans la salle dont je vous poser
quelques questions qui est propriétaire
de sa résidence principale
liés par honte
si qui est locataire
qui est propriétaire bailleur
et enfin qui est professionnel de lui
mobilier
ok merci beaucoup alors je
parler d'un sujet que vous connaissez
tous qu'on a tous déjà entendu c'est la
france des propriétaires
alors ça on a toujours entendu parce que
on l'a entendu quand on était jeunes
dans certaines familles on nous a dit
quand tu seras grand quand tu vas
commencer à travailler commence par
acheter un logement
dès que tu vouloir créer une famille etc
etc ça sera la sécurité ça sera pour toi
quelque chose que tu pourra transmettre
à tes enfants
et puis le jour autour a besoin de plus
grand tu le vendra et tu achèteras un
autre on l'a tous entendu on l'a entendu
dans nos familles on l'a entendu de la
bouche des professionnels de
l'immobilier
parce que nous un besoin que vous
achetez des logements et puis on l'a
entendu aussi de la part des hommes
politiques de certains présents la
république sauf dernier qui n'aiment pas
l'immobilier je vais vous parler de ça
et le premier serait déjà parti
c'est concernant la proportion de
locataires et de propriétaires en france
ici vous avez classement des pays
européens et on voit bien que la moyenne
européenne avait à peu près à 70% de
propriétaires et à 30 % de locataires et
en france on est en dessous de la
moyenne
on fait partie des pays où il ya
finalement en europe le moins de
propriétaires alors par rapport à tout
ce qu'on nous dit par rapport à ce qu'on
nous explique à l'attachement qu'ont les
français à la pierre c'est assez
surprenant dont je vais vous parler de
la france des propriétaires
l'asvel le classement des autres pays
mais je vous expliquer pourquoi
finalement on n'est pas tant
propriétaire que ça en france
or un élément financier c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une certaine
pression fiscale sur les propriétaires
avec des prix de l'immobilier qui sont
très élevées avec des taxes foncières
qui sont très élevées avec des charges
de copropriété qu'il faut payer et avec
un pouvoir d'achat qui finalement sur
les 40 dernières années a énormément
diminué donc avant on voulait vraiment
devenir propriétaire et puis finalement
on était locataire un peu par défaut on
était locataire parce qu'on ne pouvait
pas accéder à la propriété
et bien c'est en train de changer c'est
en train de changer là je vous montre
l'évolution de la taxe foncière on voit
que l a flambé très très fortement mais
c'est en train de changer
parce qu'on a une nouvelle génération
aujourd'hui les jeunes qui ont entre 18
et 35 ans ils sont plus
pas tous mais ils sont plus dans l'idée
de devenir propriétaire immédiatement de
leur résidence principale pour s'assurer
une vie pourquoi parce que tout a changé
avant on peut on aller passer
certainement 40 40 années 35 ou 40
années dans la même entreprise ou dans
le même métier
et puis aujourd'hui les jeunes se
rendent compte que finalement ils vont
pas rester 40 ans dans la même
entreprise ou quarante ans de métier il
ya eu un sondage ifop qui a été fait
l'année dernière qui disait que 60% des
jeunes français penser estimer avoir au
moins trois emplois différents dans leur
carrière professionnelle
aujourd'hui les jeunes ils ont d'autres
attentes que deux sens de s'enfermer
dans le crédit par exemple pour acheter
un logement
la vision des jeunes actifs
elle est plus ouverte sur le voyage plus
ouverte sur le monde
on veut moins sa tâche et je vais vous
montrer un exemple pour un appartement
rapidement un appartement à toulon 65 m²
vous acheter cet appartement
sur 15 ans et vous coûte 1300 euros par
mois 100 euros de taxes foncières c'est
les prix de l'agglomération toulonnaise
1200 euros par an les charges de
copropriété après 100 euros par mois ça
vous coûte 1500 euros par mois et en
location pour le même bien exactement
pour le même bien vous allez payer 900
euros par mois charges comprises c'est à
dire les charges de copropriété qui
reste à la charge du locataire la part
des charges qui reste à la place de
locataires une différence de 600 euros
par mois
7200 euros par an et 108 mille euros sur
15 ans alors je veux pas vous démontrez
que vous pas devenir propriétaire c'est
pas ça mais c'est juste expliquer
qu'aujourd'hui quand on dit à des jeunes
que 600 euros par mois vont être mis
dans un logement qui pourrait devenir un
boulet pour eux parce que ils sont pas
libres parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas
partir au bout du monde parce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas utiliser cet argent pour des
voyages ça devient assez compliqué à
vendre parce qu'en plus les jeunes
il souhaite
le jugement différent c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on leur propose des
logements qui n'auront qui ne
correspondent pas à ce qu'ils cherchent
ok c'est bon pour la
souvent incompris on peut devenir
propriétaire mais ce que je veux vous
dire c'est que il ya une nouvelle notion
qui n'est qui devient être locataire par
choix
avant on choisissait pas aujourd'hui les
gens qui font le choix d'être locataire
pour être libre alors sur ce sujet
je vais revenir au stade précédent
parce qu'il est pas mal pour continuer
l'explication
le problème c'est quoi c'est
qu'aujourd'hui quand un locataire
cherche un logement
nous n'avons pas les produits qui
correspondent à la demande
c'est simple prenez exemple si vous avez
recherché par exemple sur l'air
toulonnaise une petite maison de 100
mètres carrés avec trois chambres et que
vous voulez vous y installer pour la
louer
est ce que vous trouvez une petite
maison agréable à louer sur toulon
impossible donc si vous voulez trouver
ce bien il faudrait presque être obligé
de l'acheter
donc aujourd'hui la difficulté c'est
qu'on a une demande mais on a pas
d'offre en face la les professionnels
ont un rôle à jouer parce que le
professionnel d'abord il est agent
immobilier
l'agent et glisse celui qui va faire la
transaction donc c'est à nous d'amener
nos clients qui veulent être
propriétaire bailleur à acheter les bons
produits pour qu'on puisse placer ses
locataires l'intérieur pour qu'on puisse
répondre à cette demande ce qui est ce
qui est important c'est que si on ne
prend pas en compte cet enjeu si on ne
prend pas en compte le fait que les gens
vont devenir locataire par choix
yves ailleurs un problème c'est que la
concurrence comme sur le travail comme
sur beaucoup de choses
elle est mondiale donc si dans d'autres
pays ils ont la capacité de trouver des
logements en location de qualité pour
pouvoir s'y installer bouger se déplacer
ils iront se loger ailleurs ils iront
travailler ailleurs
et du coup qu'est ce qui restera
toujours un parc de logements anciens
un parc de logements qui ne répond pas à
la demande et on n'aura rien compris
mais pour faire ça il faut effectivement
que les professionnels agents
immobiliers aide les acquéreurs mais il
faut aussi que le professionnel
administrateurs de biens garantissent et
sécurisé encore plus le bailleur
souvent le comprends c'est pas trop
technique j'ai pas l'habitude de parler
devant les particuliers mme plus devant
des professionnels
donc je m'excuse pour ça
l'administrateur de bien c'est celui qui
va gérer le bien pour le bailleur
aujourd'hui si vous me donnez un bien en
gestion locative
je vais vous dire écoutez je vous prends
votre bien par exemple on prend
l'exemple d'un t2 le loyer ses 500 euros
je vais m'en occuper je vais trouver de
locataire un bon dossier et sait faire
les choses très bien et puis je vais
vous dire vous allez toucher 6000 euros
de revenus locatifs par an
mais par contre s'il ya des problèmes
d'impayés des assurances mais s'ils
apprennent un pays je pourrais l'ani
faire si un poème de vacances je pourrai
rien y faire si la personne dans le
genre je pourrai rien y faire donc ce
qu'il faut c'est que peut-être aller un
peu plus loin et que les professionnels
une fois qu'ils ont trouvé les bons
produits à vendre aux acquéreurs qui
veulent devenir bailleur on puisse
garantir une sécurité totale aux
bailleurs la sécurité totale ça serait
quoi
ça serait par exemple et toujours cet
appartement de 500 euros par mois
au lieu d'avoir aussi 1000 euros de
revenus de loyers et avec quelques
risques avec un professionnel puisse
vous garantir que vous allez avoir non
pas six mille euros mais peut-être 4500
ou 5000 euros de loyer vous allez me
donner votre appartement gestion sur un
contrat de cinq ans ou de 10 ans ce que
l'immobilier c'est du long terme
et puis moi je vous garantir c'est 5000
euros de loyer quoi qu'il arrive
quoi qu'il arrive le locataire ne paye
pas c'est mon problème je ne trouvent
pas de locataires c'est mon problème
c'est à moi de gérer entièrement autre
bien le début à la fin hélas si l'agent
mobile au départ a fait son boulot pour
ce bailleur de lui dire monsieur mais
arrêtez d'acheter ce t2 dans un immeuble
des années 70 pour le mettre en location
on en a plein par contre il faudrait
trouver un t3 avec une piste cyclable
pas loin avec un truc avec un potager
etc etc etc
pour donner envie à ceux qui veut être
locataire par choix de trouver ce
logement
il faut que le professionnel prenne ça
en compte si nous professionnels on se
rend pas compte que les choses ont
changé et que ses locataires ont besoin
de produits on mourra avec o sinon pire
on aura des plateformes digitales qui
viendront prendre ça en compte et qui
créeront là où le professionnel n'est
pas n'a pas de réponse cris créeront une
réponse pour le particulier
donc ce que je veux vous dire c'est que
aujourd'hui
on a des possibilités de répondre à la
demande mais je pense que c'est
maintenant que nous devons nous bouger
parce que vos attentes pour ce qu'ils
sont le 4 h dans la salle
j'espère que ça correspond à ce que vous
faisiez un petit peu ce qu'ils sont
cette génération en tout cas les
attentes ont changé il faut qu'on puisse
y répondre
donc la seule solution c'est de
sécuriser le propriétaire pour garantir
tout ce qu'il faut pour nos clients
voilà je remercie